III 2014 right now we're gonna talk
about the newly announced Wii U game
splatoon and joining me on stage is a
man who did not develop splatoon however
it is a man who got to play it I did get
to play it and I also just really wanted
to crowbar my way up onto the big stage
my e3 has just been running around a
different appointment so this is this is
a break for me well Maxwell Magee your
crowbar has been a resounding success
before we get to the discussion of the
game you actually did an interview I did
one of the developers right yeah one of
the actually one of the guys at Nintendo
treehouse I spoke to him just about the
game in general that's gonna set
everything up and I think we're gonna go
to that right now
thanks guys maximum again here on the e3
2014 show floor where I am checking out
splatoon alongside Corey from Nintendo
treehouse Corey thank you so much for
chatting with me thank you for coming by
it's awesome so Corey after playing this
game I have to say it is the very
definition of spray-and-pray
tell us a little bit about what splatoon
is what this game is and how please
so splatoon is a basically an action
all-new unique action online shooter
from Nintendo it's actually being
developed from our internal Studios EAD
Kyoto really excited about it
the basic objective in the game is it is
a four-on-four kind of territory control
game where you're controlling you're
basically shooting ink around the map
and you're basically at the end up at
the end of the game you want to have the
most covering the ground as possible
yeah something I thought was really
interesting is that while this is a
third-person shooter of swords actually
shooting the other players and racking
up kills frillies on the main objective
right exactly so you know you are armed
with this this kind of gun filled with
filled with pink got this ink take on
your back and you can actually turn into
a squid as well which is because why not
like you do
so once you kind of lay down that ink
turning into a squid lets you refill
your ink tank quicker you will
eventually run out of that ink so you
can reload quicker you can actually move
through the map quicker as well
inking walls will allow you to kind of
go up them maybe further access them in
the area and that's something I thought
was really cool because inking walls
like you mentioned you want to control
area but the wall isn't going to really
add to your overall score but it's gonna
give you this new bandage because you
can reach like oh my gosh so satisfying
to just like turn into a squid watch
someone come by and just pop up out send
them back to you know they're responding
I know it's almost like sometimes fall
parkour stuff you're like hanging up on
a wall just watching waiting for deuce
to come by one other thing that's really
cool about this game is how the Wii U
gamepad plays with the gameplay so
you're actually seeing once you pick up
the game you're using some of the gyro
controls with the gamepad to control
your you know tilting it slightly up and
down to kind of aim your in cart and
then you can move around of course with
the left control stick kind of aim a
little bit more at the right control
stick as well so then we've seen a lot
of the like standard aim spray gun I
know there are also super weapons you
can unlock as well but is like is that
the main weapon for this game or we're
gonna be is there like a shotgun ink gun
or anything like that so here on the e3
show floor we we've got this almost like
this bazooka cyclone super weapon shoots
each tornado is basically exactly
integrating about you know attack people
high and low it can basically you know
lay out tons of ink all over the map but
in the trailer that we released as part
of the digital event we showed off this
roller that you can actually just like
walk around and roll it I haven't played
that yet I can't wait I was actually
asking the developers I'm like that
looks so fun like that ink roller is
that's something you isn't one of the
super weapons like you build up your
meter and it unlocks for like a limited
amount of time or is that something
you'll have the entire match I'm
actually not 100% sure I know that we
have announced that you will have
multiple
superweapons win the whole game releases
so it's not gonna be limited to
necessarily that game tornado now I know
a lot of shooter communities like thrive
or plans you know getting together
playing together things like that what's
sort of online community support and
functionality can we expect for splatoon
so we haven't gone into the necessarily
the in-depth kind of online online modes
yet but as you mentioned this is
absolutely a online shooter here at e3
we've got kind of a set up more like a
land style going on right now it's kind
of simulate that online play but but
you're gonna you know have exactly what
you expect from a you know online
shooter and this game has definitely
sort of been a surprise hit I feel for a
lot of people and you guys announced it
your Nintendo Direct you're like what
you're shooting ink and you turn to a
split this is so bizarre but I know
everybody back talk who's coming
actually played it isn't like wait a
minute this is actually pretty cool and
what have you thought of that
I've waited I mean like it surprised me
I think when I first heard of it I'm
like wait a second and then once you
actually get the you know the game in
your hands and feeling you're playing
just comes alive before fun I had a
friend on on social media was like Cory
I just saw splatoon is that game is fun
as it looks because it just looks like
absolutely fun and I wish you could come
here and play it so Cory have you guys
announced win splatoon is coming out we
have announced a 2015 date haven't
locked down necessarily a month yet but
looking forward to it next year all
right well let's go ahead and get back
to work thank you so much for chatting
with me Thank You max and you folks of
course stay tuned against mod.com for
our ongoing e3 2014 coverage and now we
are back here up on the stage with
Maxwell Magee noted splatoon expert
that's right resident senior splatoon
editor as it were I also got to fulfill
a wish of mine which was to throw - a
video of myself because I knew this was
gonna come out of the show so I start
out the interview like oh thanks for
toss it to me or whatever yeah and you
stole my thunder in the process that's
my job
so splatoon what did you think about it
I had a lot of fun with it
yeah it has a lot of really great ideas
it's like obviously it's a third-person
competitive shooter but since it's from
Nintendo and has sort of this colorful
cutesy vibe to it short um the one thing
that did kind of irked me at first was
when I first started playing it you use
the Wii U gamepad and by tilting it up
and down you your character can look up
and down but then to look left and right
you use the right thumbstick so like
this combination of moving the pad and
doing the thumbstick was like a little
left brain right brain conjunction that
kind of freaked me out but I did learn
later on that you can actually change it
so that all of the looking around is
just controlled with the thumb sticks
okay it's like a normal shooter okay so
I mean how does it feel how does the
movement it feels really good the game
is super fast-paced because like you saw
in the in the interview there as you
paint the ground you can turn into a
squid and then dive into the ink of your
own color and then swim along really
fast and then you can do other things as
a squid too like they're those
chain-link gates you can turn to a squid
it just like falls straight through the
gate to get to different areas one thing
that I really like that uh that was a
kind of a titanfall move really is a you
want to control as much area of the map
in your own color as you can
that only applies to the ground so you
go around and you're painting the ground
and you're painting the ground you can
also paint the walls but it's not going
to add to your side's total score
however you can do fun things like paint
a line up the wall and then turn into a
squid dive into the wall swim up to the
top and just sort of hang out just sort
of hide up there all parkour style and
wait for somebody to come run it along
and they jump out of the wall and ambush
them and it's awesome so we've got some
Twitter questions here and then I'm
gonna just I'll do the best that I can
I'm gonna do disqualify Bob Jones
question is how long will a typical
match be how many different colors are
there release date how many different
games modes and /type /font you're not
allowed to ask literally Decker question
so we're gonna script to skip to Patrick
McCool who's okay is it just multiplayer
or is there any sort of single-player
components right now they were primarily
talking about the multiplayer component
so I can't say either way whether or not
there's going to be a media
single-player feature I don't want to
put words anybody's mouth obviously but
mostly everything they're showing off
right now is just a single-player
component obviously the game still
recently announced still early in
development so right do you know if
there's any sort of there's another
question we had about customization I'm
missing a mood that was do you know if
there's any sort of that stuff in there
so you again customization Oh character
customization it the rounds that I
played it was all just largely random
the colors that were assigned the
characters appearances were just
randomized each time so like you don't
you don't load into a game and like pick
the color of your team or anything like
that it just assigns two different
colors and then it assigns just random
character so sometimes my team was four
copies of the same character sometimes
they were all distinct and individual
themselves so I feel like at least at
this point it's all just random right
okay well that was Daniel Smith oak on
Twitter thank you that does it is it a
hard game to keep trailer was yes yes
actually the so on the Wii U gamepad it
has like the entire bird's-eye view of
the map and it'll show the paint being
applied to it so you can sort of see
where the battle lines are being drawn
what let's see what's not big oh right
here here we go this is something I
wanted to mention you didn't really do
it correctly but you
you can get back into the action super
quickly when you die and respawn by
looking down to Wii U gamepad whoa
do you actually die in splatoon that's
been worse yeah it's not yeah I mean you
do die and when I asked the guy yeah you
dot you come back to life you're a weird
paint squid monster maybe you explode
and then like reform later on I don't
want to get it but basically if you want
to get back into the action quickly you
can look at the Wii U gamepad it'll have
a little icons for all of your teammates
I mean if you tap one of those icons
you'll rock it like propel yourself
across the map and you'll just land
right where they are and then boom
you're right back into it of course
every time I tried to do that I would
drop into the match and then somebody
would just blast me cuz you die super
quick like I was surprised by how twitch
it felt because I mean obviously you
know you wouldn't expect that kind of
thing maybe from a Nintendo game
expecting to be a little bit easier a
little bit more of a softer introduction
if you will but this game like yeah you
one two three good hits from the
splatter gun and you just explode in a
shower of color Inc headshots is their
ink shipping it's all spray-and-pray
okay it's almost rain free you're not
lining up any kind of headshots or
things like that it's not gonna reward
you for like targeting a specific part
of the body it's all spray-and-pray
um you do have so there's the there's
that meter up there at the top right
corner of the screen and now it says
click when that's where you click it
down and you get access to these super
weapons so the the super weapon they
were showing off when I played it was
like this basically a paint tornado gun
and you basically you unlock it you get
it for a couple of seconds and you can
just fire at will these giant swirling
paint tornadoes they just paint large
portions of the map and will just blow
up people in one hit I mean getting shot
down in splatoon really isn't that big
of a deal um I talked about this
recently in the interview but just uh
actually killing the other opponents or
the killing or the other team isn't your
main objective your main objective is to
paint as much as the map as possible and
killing the other players this is sort
of a a stepping stone to that larger
goal when you actually defeat another
opponent they will explode in your color
so you do get a little bonus there so
they'll help like their death helps
paint more of the map in your own color
so I mean you get that kind of bonus but
otherwise like getting to a certain kill
threshold or something like that isn't
isn't what you're after all right cool
well anything else that you want to drop
in anything that we haven't quite
covered yet uh no I actually I had a
surprising amount of fun with splatoon
I'm definitely looking forward to
getting my hands on some more of it all
right thank you very much Maximo McGee
not the developers do not the developer
alright so we're going to jump to a
quick break but after this guy's we have
an incredibly special guest to be that
you do not want a man it's an actual
developer it is an actual developer very
famous developer so stay tuned